Rob Corddry, do you want
to see an invention?
Yeah, sure.
Well, it's time
for Inventor's Corner
with my best friend Kazuki!
[ Gorburger laughs ]
[ applause and cheering ]
GORBURGER:
Rob, you're gonna love it.
Take it away, Kazuki!
Hi, Gorburger!
Hi, Kazuki!
You're my best friend.
I know! You are
my best friend, too!
[ laughs ]
I like him.
And pleasure
to meet you, Rob.
Nice to meet you, too.
This is the Multi-Knife II!
Yahoo!
[ laughing ]
[ switch clicks ]
See?
Oh, look at that, Rob.
It's very sharp
and great for stabbing
into meat and onion.
It also works for haircuts,
but Rob has no need
for that,
because he doesn't have...
hair!
[ laughing ]
GORBURGER: I don't know
if it's a cultural thing, Rob,
but they really love
that bald joke.
Good one.
Really funny.
[ audience gasps ]
[ man screams ]
GORBURGER:
Kazuki, what happened?
Rob, do you think
this is part of it?
ROB:
Part of what?
[ Gorburger screams ]
What?
[ all screaming ]
ROB:
Oh... what?
Another murder!
Yes, another murder!
Ah! This is terrible.
It is terrible, Robert,
and you know what?
I will avenge
my best friend's death.
After these messages.
Let's go to commercial!
If that's not ketchup,
then we can't eat those.